i'm here at this event with me see Terry
Crews sterling k brown Morris Chestnut I
mean not believe me I'm not gonna unveil
my biceps in this crowd JK Simmons
brought his biceps to the all-star game
oh and some new deists about
Commissioner Gordon are you bulking up
because I hear you want to make
Commissioner Gordon a badass ah the the
going to the gym honestly had nothing to
do with Commissioner Gordon I just been
going to the gym you know off and on my
whole life but the last five or six
years I've been trying to just stay
pretty dedicated and fight father time
and not try to you know turn into a fat
piece of poo again well you look great
but Commissioner Gordon said you want to
make him bad ass what do you mean by
that what do you want to see him do I
think you know if you look at the
history of the character in the in the
comp you know he's a pretty tough guy
you know he's not he's not you know just
this sort of comic relief he's not just
the you know it's not just anything he's
a he's a part of that Universal and you
know in the first film that we're
currently shooting my part is not as big
as it you know knock wood will be in
some of the future films the Batman film
and I mean you know you never know sure
what's what's going to be made or what's
not going to be made but the plan is
plan a if that indeed comes to fruition
is there will be a more Commissioner
Gordon in the future and I have no idea
honestly absolutely zero idea but but
I'm lobbying right now let Commissioner
Gordon be a badass put it out there